the range of colors that homeowners
could use on the exterior of their
houses
was blank
by the community's stringent rules
regarding upkeep of property so we're
talking about the range of colors that
homeowners could use on the exterior of
their house
and it was blank by the community's
stringent rules so stringent rules that
means strict rules that they're not
going to they're not going to allow a
lot of range of colors they're going to
be very they're going to be very maybe
specific or they're going to try to
limit the number of colors that you
might want to use that's the way i'm
thinking of this now look at let's look
at the choices so the first one is
circumscribe circumscribed which means
kind of putting boundaries on things
limiting things that seems in line with
having stringent rules the range of
colors that homeowners could use on the
exterior of their houses was
circumscribed by the community's
stringent rules regarding upkeep of
property that actually feels pretty good
so i'm going to go with this one
for now that they were trying to put
kind of restraints on or putting limits
or putting boundaries which is what
circumscribed means by the communities
that the stringent rules would
essentially circumscribe the range of
colors it makes sense let's look at
these other choices the range of colors
that homeowners could use on the
exterior of their houses was bolstered
by the community stringent rules well no
the stringent rules are going to bolster
they're not going to boost the number of
colors they're not going to give you
more options it's probably going to give
you fewer options so we'll rule that one
out
the rain the the range of colors was
embellished by the community's
astringent rules no once again
embellishing means to kind of add more
to kind of put some frills on it to make
it a little bit more a little bit more
exciting if we're talking about
embellishing a story so stringent rules
are not going to embellish a range of
colors they're going to restrict a range
of colors they're not going to make it
even more more exciting more flowery
more options
so the range of colors was insinuated
by the community's stringent rules so
insinuating means
you're kind of implying something you're
hinting at something without really
saying it directly now stringent rules
seem like the type of rules that they
wouldn't try to beat around the bush
they would just get to the point they
wouldn't try to insinuate things they
wouldn't just try to hint they would be
very specific about look this is what
you can do and what you can't do so i
don't think community stringent rules
would try to insinuate a range of colors
they would just tell you look you're
either going to do this or that this is
allowed this is not allowed that's what
makes them stringent very strict rules
the range of covers
was cultivated by the community's
stringent rules well once again you know
cultivated means that you're helping to
kind of develop you know you're
cultivating a garden you're really
you're really fostering it you're giving
it nutrition you're really you're really
trying to make something blossom and
once again stringent rules that doesn't
seem like something that would try to
maybe you know cultivate a range of
colors hey let's try to think of more
colors and let's just make sure we've
thought of all the colors possible and
and all of the rest that doesn't make a
lot of sense that stringent rules would
try to do that